the FBI is now investigating the sexual
misconduct claims against judge Brett
Kavanaugh that have stalled his Supreme
Court nomination and divided American
voters in a CBS News poll out this
morning thirty five percent of people
say the Senate should confirm Cavanaugh
37% one senators to vote against him and
28 percent believe it's too soon to say
now the outside Council hired to
question Christine Blasi Ford tells
Republicans on the Judiciary Committee
that a he said she said case is
difficult to prove but quote this case
is even weaker than that major Garrett
is at the White House major good morning
good morning the White House did not
want a new FBI investigation the seventh
if you are keeping track into Brett
Kavanaugh but agreed because it was the
only way to keep Cavanaugh's embattled
nomination alive now this weekend a new
clash arose over Kavanagh sworn
testimony last week not about sexual
assault but about his drinking habits
they have the ability to pursue the
evidence he look Judiciary Committee
Democratic low bashar warned the White
House has tried to protect Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh by ordering a
narrow investigation they cannot say oh
hey only interview the people in their
neighborhood on one side of the street
the FBI will not pursue allegations from
Julie sweat Nick that Kavanagh was
present at parties in the early 80s
where women were given excessive amounts
of alcohol and sexually assaulted new
transcripts show in an interview with
the Judiciary Committee last week
Cavanaugh called sweat Nick's
allegations total BS she's lying
Cavanaugh said the sweat Nick thing is a
joke that is a farce a new front in the
Cavanaugh saga how truthful he was about
his drinking habits in high school and
college the FBI may investigate that not
drink beer to the point of blacking out
a Yale College classmate of Kavanagh
Charles Chad Ludington said Cavanaugh
tried to deceive the Senate by
downplaying his drinking habits
Ludington says on multiple occasions he
saw Kavanagh staggering from alcohol
consumption when Brett got drunk he was
often belligerent and aggressive
Ludington added he would take my
information to the FBI they have free
rein they're going to do whatever they
to do whatever it is they do on Sunday
lawyers for Christine Blasi Ford said
she has not heard from the FBI but the
FBI did interview Deborah Ramirez
another yellow college classmate who
told The New Yorker that during a
drunken dorm room party in the early 80s
Cavanaugh thrust his penis in her face
and caused her to touch it without her
consent as Cavanaugh continues to deny
charges of sexual assault and excessive
drinking the FBI is expected to
interview those at the party where dr.
Ford testified this alleged assault took
place they include Cavanaugh friends and
associates Leland Kaiser mark judge and
PJ Smith meanwhile another Yale
classmate of Cavanaugh's Chris Dudley
who played the NBA said this about his
drinking habits and alleged abuse of
alcohol he said that is Dudley Cavanaugh
never ever blacked out he'll all right
major thank you